So 7.2, we call it falsehood. And this lesson really is a
response to a common atheist objection that if God was so
big and mighty and powerful and sovereign and all good, then he would have
prevented evil. He wouldn't have allowed it in the first place.
I mean, think about it. If God can do these things, if God can just speak and
suddenly we have a universe, then why can't he prevent evil.
Years ago, I did a debate with an atheist, and this was sort of his argument.
His argument was very complex, but let me sort of summarize it as quickly as I can.
He basically said that if God existed, God would have created
a world in which only God-like objects existed and he called that
God world. And if this God world were an actual world, then all the pieces of
God world would be just like God.
There would be no suffering, there would be no evil, there would be no nothing.
Everything would be absolutely perfect on equal playing field to God.
And my response was pretty simple.
It took me some time to figure out exactly what he was saying and then hit me.
I said, well, one, why do you think this is the case?
And he said, well, because there's evil and suffering in the world.
So, well, let's put that aside for a second.
Is there anything that God cannot do?
And he said, well, if God is all powerful, then there's nothing that God cannot do.
That's why he, if he can't prevent evil, then God must not exist.
I said, that's not the case. Just because God is all-powerful and sovereign
and omniscient and all-awesome, then
does that mean that there's nothing that God cannot do?
So unfortunately, the old song, my God is so great, my God is so big, there's
nothing, that's actually not necessarily true because God could not create
a world in which only God-like objects or God-like things, things that are
equivalent to him existed because if that were the case then
God would not exist because he wouldn't be God anymore.
He would just be equal to everything else then everything would be the same as God
and it would be all things would be God and that would take us into a form of
pantheism.
So his argument didn't work but it's sort of this understanding that well why
wouldn't God do that? Well, because simply put, there's some things that God
actually cannot do. And what's important about this lesson is to help students
understand that God is not the one that's responsible for evil.
God did not create it. It's like I said last week, it's not a thing to be created
because evil is not a thing. God did not create it.
God is not responsible. And although God is doing something to remedy the situation,
he still has to allow us to have free will to make our own choices.
So this week, I would get your students thinking about the character and nature of
who God is. Have them think about, just like in the intro activity, we asked them
about things that it's impossible for humanity to do, but what about things that are
impossible for God to do? What are some other things that maybe God cannot do?
Have your students sort of think that through, of what makes God, God, and what
maybe limits does God actually have.
Now, I don't mean fun things like can God create a rock so big he can't lift it and
those strange questions like that.
That's not what I'm talking about.
But things like God cannot contradict himself.
God cannot lie. So have your students think that through to help paint a better
picture of the nature of God and exactly what he's doing in this world to
remedy the evil and the suffering that is so prevalent.
So God has morally justified reasons for allowing the temporary existence of
evil and suffering in our world.
That may seem like a cop-out, like what?
That's the best you've got? But remember what Scripture says and what Paul says in 1
Corinthians is that we only see things in part right now.
We don't have a full picture. There's still quite a bit of mystery going on.
The example I always used to give my students was the example of being a kid or
parenting my own kids is that I may know what's best for my kids, they may not
realize that I know what's best and what I'm telling them they have to do or what
I'm putting them through may seem like a terrible, terrible thing for them in that
moment. The whole world is coming crashing down on them yet I know exactly what I'm
doing and it's for their good. And that may be the case sometimes, and sometimes
it's just the case that evil is just evil, and evil just happens.
And God doesn't like it any more than we do, but he has to allow it, even
if only for a time. And as we'll see later on, when we get to more of the pastoral
approach to this question of evil, is that it can be used for something
exceptionally good. So in your small groups, I want you to start to brainstorm
a little bit about what good can come from evil.
But I also want you to, again, be very aware when I keep beating this drum, be very
aware of the questions that are coming.
If the questions didn't come last week, they may be coming this week and they may be
coming next week. They may be coming all of the weeks.
And be aware of some of the things that your students are going through.
By now, you probably know your students really well.
You probably know their families.
You probably have talked with their parents and you've connected with their families
on some level.
Do your best to be aware of some of the things that your students are going through
for two reasons. One, so you can pray with them and pastor them along, walk with
them and be there for them in the way that you need to be.
That goes without saying. But the other is when we're dealing with these kinds of
issues, you want to have an awareness and a sensitivity so that you don't say
anything that would touch the wrong nerve with your students.
Sometimes you may want to, a little bit, to get a response out of students and to
move them along, but you also want to be very, very aware of where they are so that
you can minister to them the best possible way without saying them back at all.
So rather than going down the easy road and just simply doubting God because of the
evil that we see around us. We can actually look to him for hope and know that he
has a plan, know that he has a purpose, and know that of all the things that we're
going through, it's not for nothing.
We can look to him for significant hope.